jeder von uns ist wahrscheinlich kann
man das so sagen weil wir uns nicht
leben würde aber interessanterweise ist
vielleicht du ganz andere sachen als
jemand anders der dieses video gerade
schaut und ich finde irgendwie
interessant und das ist auch ein
bisschen meine mission auf dem kanal
möglichst viele sachen zu probieren und
deshalb stelle ich mir manchmal die
challenge league mir auch heute im video
stelle einfach mal einen tag nur sachen
zu essen ich noch nie gegessen habe ich
finde es ist unfassbar wichtig neue
dinge zu probieren und wenn man es hier
mal so ein kleiner change gibt dann
macht das nicht nur spaß sondern man
lernt wahrscheinlich sogar noch sachen
übersicht und kann eigentlich nur
gewinnen dementsprechend lassen sie uns
heute gut gehen ich esse drei sachen die
ich noch nie vorher in meinem leben
gegessen habe wir sagen wir fangen an
mit einem frühstück was ich schon ganz
lange ausprobieren wollte und damit sind
wir in der küche es gibt zum frühstück
tamargo hahn ich hoffe ich spreche das
richtig aus ist ein japanisches gericht
was so viel heißt wie reich also reich
mit sehr selbsterklärend und das rezept
ist auch denkbar einfach ich habe hier
alles was ich brauche keine sojasauce
dann fügt haake das ist so eine mischung
aus seesen chili curry also so ein paar
asiatische spices dazu gibt es hier
frisch gekochten reis dennoch sehr schön
warm ist zweier habe ich hier und
frühlings viele das frühstück was jetzt
zu bereiten werde ist das lieblingsstück
von meinem lieblings koch ressort und
auch lukas gaycken würde den her
vielleicht kennt schwört ihr könnt es
eigentlich auf eine art und weise
herausfinden indem ich koche und ich bin
bisher sehr gespannt wie das schmecken
kann weil es so einfach ist aber sofern
von dem was ich kenne dass es entweder
ein flop oder
erleuchtung sein wird ganz ganz ganz
wichtig ist dass man gute frische bio
eier kauft also nichts benutzen was
irgendwie saß ist sonst sätzlich ich
glaube ich gerade in japan und so noch
strengere qualitätskontrollen wasser und
so angeht wie kochen stilecht oder
eigentlich kochen begann ich weiß ist
halt waren das kann man auch mit alten
reichs mache ich behaupte auch immer
noch ein bisschen gedämpften reiste das
reicht erstmal was wir jetzt machen ist
denkbar einfach teilnehmen wir uns von
unseren eiern
und gäbe es in die mitte dazu kommt
jetzt einen schuss von unserer sojasauce
msg mono sodium glutamat oder auch
einfach geschmacksverstärker sehr
verrufen bei uns aber eigentlich
komplett auslassen so einen halben
teelöffel rein dann noch mal so ein teil
mit telefon aber das heißt jetzt geht
die action und
[Applaus]
so ging das ganze ist so schauerlich
cremig wird der ganze rest noch mal
aktiviert wird wir können sogar ein
bisschen mehr reisen aber alles werden
aber man sieht schon das ist so schaurig
ärger das wird sofort von jaja deswegen
ist der kennt ihn er ist halt so ein
kranker kopf oder möglich die wildesten
sachen kommen wir mal hat das rezept für
den besten schauspieler nämlich je
gegessen habe gemacht und bei so vielen
anderen dingen auch und der kennt sich
sucht mit essen aus und das ist dein
lieblingsessen das haben wir hier unsere
basis so machte es kurz stehen das
füllen wir jetzt auch so wie es ist
schon in unserer schüssel das ding ist
leute ich bin sehr gespannt wie sieht
euer feedback zu dem gerichtssaal wird
würdet ihr das essen findet ihr das us
team gesagt okay die eier sind rose oder
kanal für mich ist das so ein ding wenn
ich weiß wo es herkommt durch vertrauen
habe man nämlich auch dass du zuerst
kleine kugel in die mitte jetzt kommt
das wo es wahrscheinlich spätestens
jetzt in unserer freilich die ein
bisschen eigenartig es war nur noch ein
eigelb wie gesehen die mitte leben
vorsicht nicht wir toppen das ganze mit
unserer gewürzmischung das sieht schon
richtig gut aus die ich mit frischen
frühlingswind ran wie kann das vergisst
so komplex so aus als hätte man so
richtig gekocht wird im kelly drüber
davon klein geschnitten damit unser
frühstück ernsthaft darauf capo
erwartungen
dieses schaue mir klingt anders kraft
der candy hat das japanese carbonara
dann probleme
ich habe gerade drei minuten gekocht
kann das jetzt so viel geschmack haben
geschmacksverstärker rücken und hält so
unnormal schaumig cremig es ist ein
vollmundiger geschmack 0,0 trocken oder
so das wirklich auch durch diese
gewürzmischung das ist auch so dass
diese kleine chips drin es ist sich
übels gut für mich auch sollte würde ich
so etwas authentisches also ich bin
wirklich sehr davon überrascht wie
schnell das geht beckers ist mit knapp
einfacher ist ein absolutes frühstück
für jeden tag mein favourit practice in
the world wird es nicht jetzt gerade in
diesem moment die teams zu siebeneinhalb
oder 8 815 aber wenn ich den teil von
mir ausschalten könnte der so sagt
zastrow irgendwas erst mit 19 ihr habt
ja gerade gesehen drei minuten gekocht
aber davor standen leider ungefähr zwei
stunden einkaufen also supermarkt hier
dann beim hofladen gewesen die eier
gekauft und so weiter und so fort wie
schön wäre es wenn man einfach genau die
zutaten die man braucht um ein gericht
zu kochen nach hause kommen würde und
nicht mal einkaufen müsste dafür gibt es
zum glück helfrich den sponsor des
heutigen video jetzt ist nämlich ein
bisschen zeit vergangen ich habe wieder
hunger und alles was fürs mittagessen
brauche befindet sich in diesem paket
lacht so oder so ähnlich kommt dass
nämlich zu euch nach hause wir machen
jetzt gleich einen französischen stoffel
bohnensalat wenig auch so noch nie
gegessen habe aber bevor wir ins kochen
geht erzähle ich euch kurz was zu hello
fresh an diejenigen die vielleicht noch
nie von helmut resch gehört haben oft
hilft dir jede woche zu einem
entspannten alt musste ich mir viele
verschiedene supermärkte anfahren so wie
ich das frühstück muss zusammen kriegt
einfach all das frisch zu dir nach hause
wenig aber das beste ist du musst nicht
mehr überlegen was du kochen möchte ist
sondern einfach aus einer vielzahl von
möglichen gerichten auswählen das team
am besten gefällt hella flush nimmt ihr
das lästige nachdenken ab schlägt dir
jede woche über 20 von richtigen köchin
kuratierte rezepte vor und du musst ja
einfach noch auswählen was dir am besten
gefällt ob ein kiwi bürgerhalle raps
oder eine ganz normale polonaise ist es
für jeden was dabei ist in seinem abo
kannst du jederzeit die lieferung
anpassen pausiert woanders hin liefern
lassen wenn beispielsweise im urlaub
bist du kannst auch die portion menge
anpassen der wie beispielsweise besuch
bekommst was ist also alles in der hand
die produkte sind auch alle regionalen
und die lieferung zu dir nach hause
erfolgt klimaneutral dementsprechend
kann man das ganze auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren mit meinem coach fresh mag
spaß zu nämlich in der schweiz bis zu
140 franken und in deutschland und
österreich bis zu 90 euro auf deiner
ersten vier posten dazu kommt dass halo
flash monatlich kündbar ist das heißt
ihr könnt es wirklich günstig
ausprobieren läuft eigene stellten also
klickt jetzt auf den link in der
beschreibung und sichere dir den rabatt
thrash max dankeschön ein halo flash
wird erneut unterstützen eines kanals
und ich es jetzt zum allerersten mal
französischen kartoffel boden das heißt
wir packt uns unsere kartoffeln muss zu
meiner schande gestehen das paket ein
kämpfe stehen lassen aber dass die
trasse alles für rechtsfälle auch nach
einem tag noch 50 zentimeter dicke
scheiben es ist denkbar einfach ich bin
das wasser der zwischenzeit schon mal
zum kochen das ganze sollte euch allzu
lange dauern aber es ist tatsächlich
auch ein gericht ist kann erst die
antrag von hella flush und dann das
video und ich habe mir gedacht das ist
so eine sache ist nur noch nie gegessen
habe ich muss zu meiner schande gestehen
ich glaube ich an der uni kartoffelsalat
gemacht ich hab noch nie so ein
französischen gegessen und habe die
rezepte für diese woche engagiert aller
flächenländer aber erst muss man auch
gar nicht gerechnet
so ein bisschen seite in den topf
während das ganze hier vor sich hin ich
denke kommt und herren blätter zusammen
frank schneider erfahrenes und salat
kräuter karotten radieschen alles
schneien
wäre jetzt hier die schalotte 12 minuten
angeschwitzt eben die mit schale und
jetzt das dressing machen werden finde
das cool man kann auch bei sowas immer
so kleine tipps und tricks greifen
natürlich hätte jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht
gemacht hätte vielleicht ist es ja auch
genau das was wir immer das hielt aber
nehmen wir unsere gehackten kräuter und
dill und petersilie haben wir hier
körnigen sind einheit es werden olivenöl
butter milch zitronen dressing ein
schlückchen weißweinessig ein bisschen
verein somit mir das ganze jetzt einmal
durch den stress als ich hier ihre
schlechter macht hätte ich bin immer so
konnte plastik bestehen wir soll noch
vier esslöffel vom kochwasser nehmen und
sie mit in unser dressing geben das ist
auch schon wieder so ein kleiner
allerlei techno verhängt hatte durch
teurere das schlüssige kommen sie
bekommen und dann schütten wir das ganze
ja ab und an dem wir das ganze in unsere
salatschüssel dann kommt oben drüber
unser dressing
durch das wort kartoffel bei uns bei
allen dingen text so wie jetzt so der
saft immer mehr verschwindet und in die
kartoffeln 1 werden durch viele rennen
das wirklich wichtig nicht aber wir
haben noch ein bisschen flüssigkeit und
das auch gut so ganz nicht austrocknet
wenn wir jetzt unsere salatherzen
eingeben die radieschen die clubs sehr
sehr frisch ich habe ich bock drauf das
ist so und so der ist so kompakt
geworden
der ist aber eher so
jetzt ziegenfrischkäse
krempelt das auch ohne ihren frisch und
knusprig gemüse würfelt mamma mia jetzt
bin ich aber auch wirklich gespannt und
ich werde komplett ehrlich zu euch sein
wie das ganz geschmeckt habe ich so echt
noch nicht gegessen aber ein mal
reingehen
kartoffel mitgenommen
[Musik]
peter knapp oder ziegen gibt wirklich
eine tasse honig note rein weiß gar
nicht wo der honig ist aber er ist auf
jeden fall daten das ist echt ein schön
ausbalancierter salata sich der der das
rezept ein schwimmbad denkt sich was
dazwischen krasse cremigkeit vom
ziegenkäse das ist wirklich sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr lecker durch das gute
mischung haben wir auch finde ich dass
es so charakteristisch für so einen
geilen lauwarm kartoffel sagen wir auch
so luftschicht oben auf der kartoffeln
durch den essig tendiert eher
wahrscheinlich eher zum sächsischen
kartoffelsalat oder mussten eine gute
gabe selbst kennen
das
ist wirklich sehr sehr lecker und ist
was ganz neues da fehlt nichts und ich
kein geld
also für mich auch geld war einfach da
ich konnte einfach bearbeiten video
drehen was leckeres und heute abend ist
mehr ein restaurant sich schon seit den
ersten mal wo es gesehen habe testen
wollte aber ich habe nicht mal leute
gefunden gehen gehen wollten so wie sehr
ist beim restaurant in gera das ist ein
äthiopisches restaurant und ich habe mir
gedacht spare ich mir das auch für ein
tag essen wie in äthiopien aber ich
heute schon so lange hin was wir heute
mal essen und ich bin mir sicher ich
habe noch nie irgendwas aus der
türkischen küche gegessen deshalb
schauen wir mal es ist schon gerne
geruch hier drin
wir werden uns gleich einen job hatte
bestellen also zum teilen das ganze das
ganze wird auf in gera brot serviert
deshalb plane wie ich jetzt gelernt habe
und kay ward bestimmt alles vollkommen
falsch aus aber gucke einfach erstmal
was kommt und dann probiert ist ja wie
gesagt gegessen habe ich bestimmt noch
nicht und auch wieder wie bei 1 tag
essen wie in ghana nur mit händen ohne
stärker bestimmt und das warten ist auf
jeden fall sehr erträglich wenn man sich
sehr sehr schön sind hier im innenhof
und kanten ich dachte dass ein fall der
kleine laden riesengroß und
sieht richtig gut aus oder krank also
richtig farbe nastran geisteskrank auch
zu dieser zwiebel sport ja das ist
richtig so und ich finde aber auch die
das in gera brot ich habe direkt an
crêpes gedacht ich hab mich wirklich aus
wie quasi sowie herzhafte crêpes oder
galette oder wie auch immer sieht sehr
sehr sagt der mann direkt rein dann
erstellen mit händen in den äthiopischen
zwiebel schmortopf eines
co2 also unnormal egger hat mir hat mir
gewisse schärfe aber ich bin gerade
insbesondere von dem büro total man
merkt den sauerteig hat richtig power
und erlebt sauerteig bringt ja auch
immer so einen ganz eigenen
aber das wirkt das lenken uns richtig
gut
als ich fragte zum beispiel refresh
eingeliefert da sitzt der mann nach und
nach
alle kommentare jetzt hübscher mann wwf
oder suchen macht so spaß zu essen
sowieso leute ihr werdet wahrscheinlich
in der nächsten zeit wenn dann die küche
oder ist brauchen wir mal so das ganze
umfeld noch viel besser kennen derweil
wird einfach also immer an einem ort
sind das wird richtig räumt darauf aber
ich nehme mit final von lg
komplett ist es so wenn man jetzt so
date mit lara haben wir so hierhin und
des sowas neuesten die warst du denken
gesprächsthema besitzt so hierdurch ist
das so werde das erkundet ich mag
wirklich aber auch dies mit den händen
essen intuitiv erwartet was soll ich
sagen also ich bin umgehe erfahrungen
dank
einfacher mache ich auch schon grüße
auch ein monopol bei mir gesagt hat ich
muss hier mal essen gehen also es wäre
jetzt sich das wäre dumm sich zu fragen
so wie schmeckt das recht das ist
einfach ein ganz ganz eigener geschmack
der einfach sehr schwer zu vergleichen
ist oder das ist so vieles steckt
vertraut zum beispiel sehr vertraut
dieser rote linsen du bist was ganz
eigenes aber selbst über eine sache wie
eine zwiebel sport opfer im endeffekt
ist ja gulasch augen zwiebel sport aber
das war immer so ein zwei gewürze dann
dem ganzen noch so eine kleine biegung
geben und dann ist es wieder was ganz
neues beim nächsten mal wenn ich was es
kann nicht sein dass mit harry in gera
leute wir haben fast die ganze platte
demoliert es ist wirklich krass wie
dieses in gera und dann doch noch rein
haut so der sauerteig das ist schon sehr
sättigend
kringe es aber hin nichtsdestotrotz ich
glaube mein highlight heute bisschen
traurig für mich das ist die einzige
sache die ich nicht selbst zubereitet
hat aber alleine so von dem neuheit der
hat so krass also richtig geil
nichtsdestotrotz auch mittagessen war
super ganz normalen hätte frühstück sehr
sehr interessant ich gebe dem hier aber
nur neun von zehn und würde sagen wie
dabei einiges erlebt und vielleicht kann
ich euch inspirieren auch ein paar neue
sachen ausprobieren falls ja das
schmecken falls nein was euch alles
andere schmecken was ist wenn das
guthaben